i want to bring you uh breaking news and  the latest statistics  regarding covid19 are in i can tell you  that 59 937  new cases have been recorded in the last  24 hours that is down on yesterday's  figure of  just over 68 000. so  what's that around 8 000 fewer  and there have been 1035  deaths registered in the past 24 hours  that of course within  28 days of a positive test once again  down from  yesterday's figure of 1325 but it's uh  yet another day running isn't it that  these figures are above  a thousand for a fourth day running so  although the figures are down  on what was uh reported yesterday what  is important to say it's the  start of the weekend now so uh the  figures may need to be adjusted at the  start of the week to account for  the number of reports that are coming in  so figures  are down but nevertheless still they  will cause  for provide the cause for concern